on sent un peu fatigué la musique je
vois je suis un peu fatigué donc en gt
parce que je suis en plus j'ai autre
chose à faire peut-être dans ma vie tu
vois peut-être temps de se reposer un
petit peu de penser un père moi ça fait
15 ans que je t'envoie un cyclone tu
vois
[Musique]
sur place de voir qu'on fait sur trois
millions de personnes et tu vois enfin
visuellement c'est infini et que tu vois
tu as des centaines de milliers
d'enfants c'est trop voit donc tu dis
bon moi je suis là c'est vrai que si je
peux apporter mon aide moi et qu'on est
dit comme ça c'est toujours bien je me
dis problème en fait il est immense je
pensais pas je pensais pas autant
donc je me sentais je me sentais
vraiment moi je me sentais impuissant
[Musique]
se dit que c'était bien aussi de faire
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
important
je parle beaucoup de mes enfants parmi
les 500 enfants sinon j'ai pu rencontrer
cette semaine là j'ai eu une spéciale
feeling avec elle et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs c'est la première personne
qu'elle voulait revoir c'est aussi à 60%
des raisons pour lesquelles je suis
retourné là moi aussi fait c'est par la
leçon par la leçon par le son que j'ai
pu prendre en la rencontrant et partout
le contexte tu vois le fait que ces gens
n'aient rien ne fait que ces gens aient
un sou virtual un sourire que magnifique
alors qu'avec elle a beaucoup souffert
c'est plein de choses c'est plein de
choses quand je rentre manger au jam au
confort tu vois mes enfants mangent bien
ils vont à l'école
elle est comme ça donc c'est plein de
choses qui font que c'est une prestation
de mai
mais pour moi dans la situation
maintenant ce que je peux apporter à mes
enfants et les priorités de base sont
celles là c'est ceux des enfants et
s'occuper
le bonheur n'est pas forcément forcément
on va en avoir dans la course à l'argent
ces rappels c'est un peu comme je t'ai
dit je vais là-bas déjà pour moi
franchement je reviens c'est une tarte
comme je l'expliquais je peux pas me
permettre de dire et j'ai faim je peux
pas me permettre d pas finir mon
assiette c'est plein de chez plein de
petites choses comme ça finalement qui
font qu'elles font l équilibre de vie
moi je sais que j'ai une vie n a pas été
facile vraiment pas mais
elle est vraiment ma vie elle est
vraiment c'est vraiment de la rose
comparé à la scène tu vois donc c'est
que souvent ce plan est donc ça va je
pense à elle je vous écris mais elle a
changé beaucoup de choses dans ma vie